[Music]  Sunday night's Game of Thrones finally  gave us a very important introduction  Daenerys Targaryen meta Jon Snow so I  assume my lord  you're here to bend the knee I am NOT  but while the meeting did not disappoint  there were actually two other moments we  just can't stop thinking about first  Cersei slayed us all with the fate she  gave to a Laureus and those who die here  in this house you will be here watching  what she does you'll be here the rest of  your days and second another fierce  female moment before saying cheers to  death Olenna revealed the truth to Jaime  about his son  Joffrey's demise I'd hate to die like  your son clawing at my neck foam and  bile spilling from my mouth must've been  horrible for you as a Kingsguard was a  father it was horrible enough for me  you